I lost about two million pounds against
kovski
iall go poor iall kind of felt
Invincible um you know the money's
always going to be coming um I'm going
to be a millionaire soon and you start
telling yourself that and it's it's no
problem earning £99,000 a week and we
can't pay the mortgage or we can't go
out for dinner got about £250,000 put in
my bank that's $500,000 sort of in
today's money yeah and I spent it in six
weeks
what a what a what a what an
absolute what a what a
[Applause]
[Music]
aute ah what a lead well one topic I've
always wanted to talk about on this
podcast is gambling because in my
opinion it's probably the biggest
concern in our game at the moment
unfortunately the hard thing to talk
about it is finding people who are happy
and open to talk about gambling
addictions and that's where today's
guest comes in but there's certainly a
lot more to his story than just gambling
many refer to him as the most gifted
soccer player we have seen in this
country he's also spent many years
playing in the biggest league in the
world in the English premiership and
probably most of you will know him as
the Wellington Phoenix goal scoring
machine he's someone whose openness and
honesty has always impressed me every
time I've heard him speak it is of
course the legend who is Paul Eiffel
welcome mate thank you that was some in
thater really test my reading
but now I appreciate you coming on like
I said I've heard you speak um first
time was at the Hurricanes maybe four or
five years ago and then last year again
at the Crusaders and each time I've
heard you speak I've um related to a lot
of it and I've always thought man that's
such a powerful message and something
that I think could be shared and help so
many players CU like I said I think
gambling is a massive problem in the
society and especially the game at the
moment yep I'd agree and you've
obviously been through it and um just
the accessibility of it now is is pretty
dangerous these days two EAS everybody's
sponsored by a betting company and then
they have a moment people who get
suspended for betting it's like oh hold
on yeah you know you're happy to take
the money but the minute somebody Falls
foul of it it's a it's a long suspension
so there's there's work to be done yeah
100% so I'll be Keen to go through your
journey because it's a it's a such a
cool story as well but alongside it go
through the gambling so um growing up I
think you born in Brighton yeah born in
Brighton South down the South Coast um
supported Brighton and HOV albian who
were flying now in the Premier League
but back in back in my day they were in
the old division three nearly got
relegated out of out of that into sort
of non- League football and true
survived on the last day and I used to
go and watch them you know with with
friends and family and that was pretty
cool they were pretty average back then
so it wasn't like you sort of aspired to
to play for them it was always looking
Beyond and looking in the what was it
the old first division um and wanting to
play football and never thought I'd have
a career in it being honest um well you
get did um I didn't think so when I was
younger and then I think I probably got
to about 12 13 and and realized that I
was getting in different rep teams and
people were starting to say oh you could
be a professional and but for me it was
just fun I just loved playing it was
never about you know the money or fame
or anything like that I was from a
little town called wooding Dean just
outside of Brighton and I think there
had been one player in the last 50 years
that had become Pro so it was kind of
didn't really think too much about it
just I'll play and if one day I can get
paid my dad played locally oh yeah and
was on like you know 30 pound $60 a week
or whatever that would be over here yeah
and I remember thinking oh if IU can get
that I can get to you know 2530 pound
I've cracked it I've probably done have
to work when you're a kid you don't
understand you know I mean you know you
get your pocket money of a pound or two
pound and you're going and buy sweets
you think if I get 25 times out I must
be yeah I must be I must be fine be a to
drive around and get me own house and
you've got no idea so it's it's none of
that and it it slowly I think when
you're in it does become a job um and
that's when you kind of I kind of fell
out of love with it for a time yeah and
then back in in love with it later on we
can talk about that later so when did
you get your first sort of experience
where you're like oh I'm actually I'm
going here um I was playing I was 16
years old playing for a team called
saltan um again just outside of Brighton
and I started scoring goals in the men's
team and you're getting in the local
paper and that was quite a buzz I'm
still at school yeah um and I'm on the
back of the paper you know scored a goal
scored a double or something and you
know I feel they always used to love the
Towers the Eiffel Towers above them all
would be like headline um I remember
getting sacked for my first job actually
because I I phoned in sick and it was
like my second ever game and I scored a
double and I'm on the back of the
paper H that one and I'll go into work
on on the Monday they're like you told
us you were sick and then you've been
scoring goals for Sal oh Jesus that was
that was you know my first taste of Fame
I suppose um but I absolutely absolutely
loved it and and carried on playing for
that that season and the end of that
season I got my trial at mil um and then
managed to crack that and then I was off
into the sort of pro environment I
suppose true so as soon as you made that
you uh you had a contract and you were
getting paid yeah so what I did is um I
I was playing well in that team I got
off of three different trials so I had a
trial at um I had a trial organized at
Portsmouth which was about I don't know
an hour and a half down the road and
this was before mobile phones were were
around so we um we traveled traveled all
the way down there with my dad and and
we get to the ground and it had been
piss sit down all day and uh I walk into
the ground and there's puddles in the
pitch and I'm like there's no one around
I said to my dad I reckon the game's off
yeah and um we go and find out the
groundsman he's like there's no game
here today son and I'm like so my first
trial was you know rained off so we
drive back home never heard from
Portsmith again that was that was it so
then my second trial was was at M and
dad was at work on the day so I couldn't
get out there so I spoke to the chairman
of little salt de and he said oh I'll
drive you up there yeah so I drive up to
the game and um
he um we stopped up at a garage and he
said do you want something before the
game I said yeah and again being a kid
know nothing about nutrition so he said
what you want so I picked up a pie a m
bar and a can of Coke so I drank that go
go and play a turn up when we're playing
for the M was reserves versus Crystal
Palace reserves I see their lineup and
they had a boy in their team Bruce Dyer
who just become the first million pound
transfer as a teenager holy and there's
little old me drinking me can and Co I
was just in all of these players and I
went out and played and I was absolutely
so far on my depth I was a
and with about I play they played me for
90 minutes which was crazy cuz I was
terrible and I used to be quick back in
those days and I just wanted that one
chance you know show people what I could
do ball was lost in the halfway line and
I I got played in cuz the the center
back played a sort of short pass back to
the coer and I I'm through from the
halfway line so this is my moment so I'm
going to make sure but you've got a
million things going through your head
because you know this is your moments
I'm like right I'm going to I'm going to
go around him no no no no I'm I'm going
to curl it and I'm going to chip him
everything I thought of and then I get
there and I'm like [__] that I'm just G
to whack it so I got to hit it as hard
as I can it takes a tiny little bubble I
just missed the ball completely fall
flat on my face I've got like you know
mud in my mud in my face grasping my
hair and I'm just I just want the ground
to swallow me up so game finishes I go
up I get changed I go up to the um
director's box and by this point my dad
had turned up you know come from work
and he'd watch the game and yeah my
dad's a um from Barbados big you know
big sort of I wouldn't call him grumpy
but a big guy that's not doesn't really
show his emotions and I got into the
director's box and he just he's never
hugged me in his life and he just put
his arms out and it was one of them hugs
to say unlucky son right up so oh my God
my one chance I've killed it and then
the the director of football and the
chief Scout came up to me and said you
know thanks for coming up how do you
think he went and I was like I'm so
sorry to waste your time that was that
was awful was miles out my depth and
they were like oh look we knew you'd be
out of your depth and they said we've
been watching you for weeks you don't
know this but we've been we've been
following your games we've been watching
you um we just wanted to see what would
happen if we threw you out of your depth
and see what you do and they said what
we loved is every time you got knocked
off the ball you tried to get back on it
every time you lost it you tried to win
it back um it didn't matter how many
times you gave it away you just kept on
trying they said we needed to see if you
had the work ethic and the resilience
ohol we can help you the rest I'm like
Jesus it's funny because you never know
and it was a thing mom and dad had
always said like always give your best
no matter what because you you never
know um and that was such a such a good
lesson for me and they said look here's
a year deal a yts a used training scheme
it used to be yeah so you basically
signing up to go on you know [__]
wash toilets andain paint changing rooms
and clean boots and do a bit of football
on the side and the money was was awful
I think it was I think it was 440 a week
it's $80 a week it was your dream but it
i' C it so I thought I might be able to
buy my own car now um so that that was
it um you you go in there you do your
year and then at the end of the year you
they decide whether you're going to get
a pro or not um and there's like they
call it signing day pretty much and you
literally congregate in the carart with
all the boys and then you wait in wait
your turn and you have to go up to the
gaffer's office yeah see the gaffer and
he just basically says we're going to
sign you or we're not so like boys I've
been playing with all year go up to the
got up into the office told they're not
signing come down the stairs in tears
[__] um and then I had a mate of mine
Tim K who went on to play in you know
four World Cups BL I had a great career
went up got a pro come back down I on
£250 a week $500 a week so buzzing
another one of my mates went up a
goalkeeper he got signed as well same
sort of money so I'm thinking I was top
scorer in the youth team that year and
in the
reserves I'm think I'm I'm I'm getting a
deal I'm getting a deal so I got sit
down he was a big scary guy called Billy
bonds and um used to be West Ham player
like a legendary player and every
everybody was scared of him like he used
to go in the gym and just he'd be
smashing out like weights that were way
too heavy for everybody and he I think
it would do it just to scare us a little
bit the young boys yeah so I sat down
I'm thinking oh just just you know I
hope this starts well and he goes all
right son how do you think think you how
you think you've done this year and I
was just about to say I'm top score and
he went before you even start I think
you're a lazy little [__] I'm like I
straight away I sat my hands like this
thinking confidence I'm in trouble I'm
in trouble oh my God I didn't see this
coming he said um he said I think you've
got ability and he said um you know we
got you in for your work at it but I
think you've let that slide a little bit
he said I'm going to give you a month
between now and the end of the season he
said you need to go and show me what you
can do so I'm like oh Jesus wasn't
expecting this I'll come back down tell
the boys and that's it's not normally a
thing you know you have sign or you're
not so I was the only one in that
situation so rang my mom and told her
what had happened she was expecting me
to you know get it or not get it m she
said well got pull your finger out make
sure you you run it at the weekend I
think this was like a Thursday and we
played on the weekend so we went and
played CH and away on the weekend in the
youth team I scored a hat-trick oh yeah
then we played in the reserves against
gillham in the week I scored four so
seven goals in two games so then the
Friday after that they call me back in
the office yeah and um same thing up the
stairs sit down son sat down he said all
right well done well done you've had a
good week um you showed me what you can
do he said there's a contract so I've
never seen a contract in my life you
know I've signed a youth training scheme
but it's so it's a one pager this is a
proper professional contract so at the
time I had I had my first agent so I
said ah can I can I take this and show
my agent and he said sign the contract
or [__] off I'm like yes [__] what do I
do so I'm pretending I know what I'm
doing looking through I have no idea
what I'm looking at looks good yeah it
looks all right so get to like the money
page yeah and it was um I think it was
9090 so in my mind I'm doubling my money
yeah I'm thinking that sounds right to
me so I signed the contract shake his
hand walk out find a phone box like
there's no mobiles like I said so find a
phone box bring my mom mom I'm Pro I've
made it sign of the year and like she's
buzzing like over the moon because she
knows what what it means and um she goes
what what are you getting I said I
double my money she brilliant I'm so
pleased with you she said um where you
going to stay cuz I've been in in Diggs
you know in home
um I said oh didn't I didn't look in the
contract for that and she said what
about expenses if you want to come back
to you know come back to Brighton said
yeah I don't think that was in there
either and she's like you've just gone
in and signed a professional contract
you're now on less money than you were
you train you need to get back in there
go back in So GE GE I think I've made a
mistake here and he just looks at me and
he goes That's football son off you go
and he sends me back
out I I go back to the home stay and the
home stay lady was the head chef at the
club and she'd been given the nod that I
was signing Pro that day yeah so there's
like banners up and congratulations she
made a nice dinner I felt I I was like
I'm really sorry I feel sick went up to
my room and I was in bits I just didn't
didn't know what to do I was like I've
signed Pro and I've just messed it all
up I was snuck out to the shop and got a
packet of bloody Jeffer cakes that was
my dinner on the day I signed went went
to sleep woke up the next morning went
back in the assistant coach grabs me
Steve grit his name was he said the
gaffer wants to see a go up and go up
and see him so I went up to see the the
gaff again he said look son we' got to
look through your contract we're going
to add in um this and we're going to add
in that and we're going we're going to
make it whole but he said um the lesson
here is when you come in to sign a
contract make sure you bring your
agent did you have the opportunity to
bring your agent no absolutely not
absolutely not so he just Ming me off
just being a dick I was thinking what
would you have done differently in
hindsight like in hindsight if I known
that the thing is they're clever because
they get you when you are on your own
and you're a young kid like if you're if
a senior player it happened later on in
my career and I was like just ring my
agent yeah and you know you got a bit
more confident you play played 200 games
I've never played a pro game yeah so in
my mind I'm thinking I've got to do as
I'm told here so you just get a little
bit bullied and I wasn't the only one
there was different circumstances where
young boys got bullied into contract
then the agent would be like why' you
even employ me like well I was just
doing what I was told
so right what a start what a start to
Pro footy yeah it was it was it was it
was good though it was good it was um it
went quickly it went well quickly from
there yeah had you you started your
gambling by the stage yeah I had but I
you know I look back at it and think I
probably had a problem right way back
then but didn't even realize it was a
problem I was just starting out so when
did that start what age do you remember
like your first sort of I reckon 14
maybe 13 14 my granddad was um addicted
to gambling and I didn't I didn't know I
was a kid you know with had no idea yeah
and he used to take us there's a place
called The Palace pier and it had it was
just a Place full of what you call
pokies here so fruit machines and then
rides at the end so you could go and
spend your whole day there so my
granddad would take me down there give
me10 pound and I'd be in playing the
machines I wasn't supposed to be it was
over 18 it's all the bright light it's
all exciting um thinking nothing of it
and then I got to 15 and started my out
a paper round and scratch cards had just
come out and the the English Lottery had
just started so I think I was getting
paid on like 12 13 a week from us and
and I ended up I'd get that and I'd buy
scratch cards and then whatever I won i'
just buy more scratch cards so there was
never amount that I'd win was ever
enough i' just spend it all on scratch
cards no matter what I won and then do
my paper around again and go around and
in the end my mom was like I was I was
supposed to pay for phone bill that was
what it an IT amiz phone bill and every
week I couldn't pay for it cuz you sp
scratch card she like where's your money
going I don't you don't do anything you
go to football you come back you go to
school you come back where's your money
going so she went into the shop to find
out she thought I wasn't being paid or
something yeah and they were like well
we just pay him in scratch cards so
she's like he's 15 he's not even allowed
scratch card he's 16 so don't so I got
banned from byy scratch that should have
been the first sign really there was
there was an issue but I suppose I just
played pokes and stuff up until probably
17 maybe just 18 and then we were in the
Chang rooms one day and one of the young
boys in the team had a horse tip and he
said uh he said you bet on horses and I
said no no idea about horses my Grandad
used to watch horses and I used to watch
it and think this is so boring who cares
um and then had this like I said had
this horse tip and he said I said would
you would you need to put on it he said
how much money you got and I had2 left
on my on my pay and he said just put
that on he said if it wins you'll win
win90 90 I'm like okay I said what
chance he got he said no he a he's a
banker yeah which they always yeah so I
put my put my 20 pound on watch the race
and the minute the race started I felt
something it was like oh now I've got
something on it now I get why people
like this and I'm buzzing to get this
horse home it's like I was riding it and
and it only goes in bloody winds isn't
it so that was probably the worst no
mate I wish to God that [__] horse
got beit but it wins I win 90 I'm like
that was easy so now now I'm in so then
every week I'm asking got any more tips
got any more tips so and the thing is it
started quite well the tips you were
giving me most of them were winning or
or getting close and you know I was
making a bit of money so all of a sudden
the money that I'm earning I'm now
doubling I'm trebling whatever yeah and
then you you sign a new contract so all
of a sudden my 90 I think went up to
£350 so then you bets go up a creep up a
little bit because it's not the same
winning that amount you want to win a
little bit more yeah then doing well in
the first first team suddenly I go from
350 I think it's 800 so now it's like my
my bets have gone from £10 to 50 or1
yeah and that's it and you on the
slippery slope and you don't even
realize you're on it because you're
earning quite good money you're a young
guy all your mates back home are working
hard for a living and earning you know a
quarter of what you're earning so I'm
still able to go home take my mates out
you know have a good night still have
money in my pocket so you don't feel
like there's any problem and you kind of
I think as I got into my 20s I kind of
felt Invincible um you know the money's
always going to be coming uh I'm going
to be a millionaire soon and you start
telling yourself that and it's it's no
problem and then it's not till way later
on that you that you realize the career
is going to be a lot shorter than you
think it's going to be yeah you're
mentioning the tips earli was that like
a once a day type setup or was that it
ended up like that and then was it did
it become yeah I I I don't think there
was a point where I tipped over I think
you just slowly yeah go up up the hill
sort of thing and then you're like oh
[__] I'm I'm gambling every second of
the day and there were times when I
would I would gamble before put my bets
on before training in the morning um I'd
go and train we'd have lunch we
sometimes train in the afternoon then
I'd check all my bets then I'd finish
work finish football go into The Bookies
till like 5: yeah have some dinner if it
was in the summer there's evening racing
so then I'd go back in The Bookies at
like 700 till 9:00 and if I hadn't got
my buzz I'd go to the casino till
midnight and then I'd just rinse and
repeat every day um and you're earning
good money so you you never really too
far behind you know what I mean and
you've got mates that are earning good
money that don't gamble so if everyone
needed to borrow 500,000 £2,000 no
problem yeah they know you're good for
it yeah so you've always got credit and
I think that's a problem too yeah and
obviously back then you had to being the
bookmakers so yeah so it's different so
as I as I got older um I think I was I
moved to Sheffield in 2005 and internet
Bank internet gambling just started yeah
so all of a sudden I'm able to bet on my
computer um you know then you can bet on
your smart phone yeah and it doesn't
feel like you're spending money then um
and my betting went through the roof at
that point um because it was just
numbers on the screen and it didn't feel
real so whenever I went into a booking
that to actually hand over cash my bets
were pretty similar as they always had
been but I yeah when it was on and then
I got a when I went to Sheffield I
actually got a bookmaker who would give
me credit so I had £25,000 of credit
every two weeks which and I wasn't even
earning that to pay it so I was that was
stupid in the I was always going to be
behind yeah um but again you a bit of
bravado how did you get to that point
like how how are they giving you that
much credit because of what you earn
because you're a professional they'd
look and think well he's good for it he
can't go anywhere he's in the public eye
yeah so we've kind of we've kind of got
him where we want him and what happened
was I'd signed for Sheffield my teammate
was a guy called Keith Gillespie oh yeah
I've seen the book I haven't read it's a
banger book so his book is held not to
be a football millionaire yeah and he
lost7 million in his career so I signed
for sheffi he's my roommate oh true so
it was a mess so was bad anyway we were
ridiculous like we used to bet on
raindrops racing down the window and
flyers landing on walls and we'd have to
we 500 each and you pick a fly each and
whichever fly made it round all four
walls you pay the other one the money
like £500 yeah it's just now it sounds
ridiculous at the time it was just
that's what we did and then we'd be
betting on anything you know if there
was no football on we'd be betting on
ice hockey somewhere or we' be bet on
the NFL know anything about it but you
just look at the league and you look at
the stats and you go give us something
to watch something to do that's that's
the football was kind of going on on the
side yeah I guess that's a big part of
it too for professional athletes is how
much downtime you've got especially on
tour I think that's the issue and and on
tour like off tour you can go and play
golf yeah and a lot of the boys play
golf or gambled I was terrible at golf
so it was always the gambling and then
on tour even sometimes the golfers have
got nothing to do so I think that's
that's difficult trying to manage that
you've got you know easy to accessible
money you can get a lot of credit um and
you sometimes searching for that buzz
that you haven't got on training days or
on game day so it's kind of a bit of a
hot bed for it I suppose yeah made it's
crazy and we where was your football at
the stage for the most part going okay
yeah um up until probably I got to
Sheffield and and we got promoted to the
Premier League and so things were going
well on the pitch yeah and it probably
it probably hit me the next move I moved
um I got into the Premier League and
probably just didn't I was too much of a
luxury I think for the Premier League
like I was a good Championship player I
don't think I was I think I was good
enough for the premier league but I
don't think I worked hard enough and we
had a team that had just been promoted
and we needed like 11 Grinders you know
there was no way we were going to St in
the league with 10 Grinders and one guy
who thinks he can do a little bit less I
was maybe that guy and I probably didn't
realize that till it was too late so I
moved back to Crystal Palace in the
league below um and just I had a
terrible time with injuries I think in
two and a half years I had 16 hamstring
injuries which is just ridiculous I was
it just felt like I was always either
rehabbing or just coming back from one
or doing a f test before because it was
still sore um so they never saw the best
of me and and at that point I think the
gambling went through the roof because I
was always injured I'm searching for
that buzz and and at that point my selft
talk just went to [__] and it's
something I coach now so I talked to the
you know the young boys about their self
talk I wish i' realize how important
that was cuz I'd be G to games and
because I was sort of half injured I'd
be thinking oh I hope he puts me on the
bench I don't want to start yeah so then
the minute I get there and he's telling
me I'm starting I'm already behind yeah
and then I go out and I'm [__] and he
takes me off after 45 minutes yeah and
then it next week same [__] you know
what I mean we never I never got out of
that funk so probably at that point I
went I decided I'd go and see a
counselor to talk a little bit the
gambling but I was having some issues
then you know now you'd probably be
actually diagnosed with depression back
in those days but it wasn't such a thing
you're getting therapy I didn't tell
anybody didn't even tell my my wife um
just sort of did it did it on the sly
trying to get off off the gambling
trying to sort my head out get myself
talk right the football had gone to [__]
at that point really M so how long had
you been with your wife or how when did
you meet her um oh Jesus um I better get
this right yeah we we met in
2004 um I just played in the FA Cup
Final just split up with my ex and
absolutely wasn't looking for anybody
and we and we met and quickly I quickly
told her I loved her after about 10 days
um which she loves loves reminded me of
that one yeah yeah we'd been on a night
out and i' yeah had a few too many and
told her um but we're still together
yeah um so it was what was it nearly 19
years so um yeah she's she's been
unbelievable because um and I think it's
one of them you don't realize how
unbelievable she's been until you have
these conversations how is she still
with me to be honest you know and I
think when you're when you're a
professional athlete you feel like
you're the one and she's punching above
her weight and then you know you retire
and you realize you got no money left
you're not as fit as you used to be
you're not as good-looking as you used
to be um and she's still around so it's
like I better count my blessings here um
so certainly yeah I've put her through
through a lot um and yeah when you have
these conversations you sort of step
back and go geez I'm I'm pretty lucky
that she did hang around and still still
around yeah yeah so were you hiding the
gambling from her was she aware of the
gambling when we when we met I think I
was 20 there's 5 years between I think
it was 24 she was 19 and we had a couple
of nights out and then like on the
second or third night out I took her to
the casino oh yeah um and she's a uni
student know so she's got no money and
I'm you know spending 500,000 she's
probably think oh this
yeah um but wouldn't have known you know
the back story she didn't know what I
was earning or any of that stuff and she
didn't really understand football she
was she was a rugby uh rugby from a
rugby Family actually all her family had
played she' played um so I just didn't
really get football she just thought i'
played for like the local the local
football team really sort of thought I
worked and you just coming off the fa
cap final yeah she she she literally had
no idea which was crazy but it was cool
it was kind of what I what I needed um
and I knew she liked me for me and then
as I remember inviting her to the first
game at mil and she thought she was
coming and you know there was going to
be one man in his dog there and there
was like 10,000 people and she's like oh
this is all chanting name this is this
pretty serious he and I'm like well this
is my job yeah oh so you know that was
that was early on so she she quickly um
got used to I suppose the lifestyle and
didn't know too much about what was
going on and was thought you know he's
earning good money if he wants to bet a
bit that's cool she wasn't going to stop
me because it was a new relationship and
it probably wasn't until later that that
she realized that oh [__] like this is
this is serious he's he's in the
bookmakers every day yeah this is not
just a Pastime this is this could be a
problem Yeah you mentioned about being
the um being the final and the I guess
all the publicity what was it like for
you just going out in public I've just
finished that Beckham doco was it was it
a little bit like that for you no no he
was he was another level I think I think
with him I looked at I watched that do
and I was thinking [__] you always think
you want to be that guy but you can't do
anything I look at the time when I think
they showed him g into like a theme par
yeah barely get a ride you know what I
mean he's just he's signing a and he's
such a nice guy yeah and I was just
thinking I don't know if I'd ever want
that like that's way too much way too
much yeah so I think I think that's why
I enjoyed coming here when you come to
New Zealand if you're a football fan you
like the Phoenix if you're not a
football fan you don't even know plays
for the pH so they just leave you alone
and as long as the team are doing okay
you don't get any abuse whereas back in
England I play for Sheffield United
sheff Wednesday are in the same town so
there was certain bars that I couldn't
go in certain places I go to restaurant
sometime and and and get booed out of
there almost you know what I mean yeah
so you don't get that here um so there's
a real tribalism back in England and you
know you you've got 92 professional
League clubs there's a lot of people
that don't like you and it's just
because of your job and I remember
having arguments with people on nights
out people would come and start fights
with me because of who I played for yeah
and I'd be like what do you do and he'd
be like I'm a plumber and I'm like well
if the plumbing company across the road
comeing up for you double your money you
going to stay loyal to your little
Plumbing crew or you're going to go
across the road oh yeah and sometimes
they get it and sometimes idiots they
wouldn't but you know I think again at
that point it was it was more of a job
than anything else and I saw it as as a
way to to pay the bills and had fallen
out love a little bit with it yeah it's
interesting cuz football fans over there
do seem like whole different level like
it is another level like it's it's all
it's it's cool and I kind of miss it but
like you know if you're if you're a
sheffeld United fan and it's Sheffield
United against sheffeld Wednesday if you
win that game you'll get into work with
your with your chest puffed out next
week because you know the cheff of
Wednesday fans will be with their heads
down yeah it was so they made it clear
that you don't not lose Chev Wednesday
and when I was at Mill it was the same
you know their their big rivals were
Charon and West Ham and I remember there
was a time when we were awful in the
league but the fans would be like listen
don't worry about the league you do not
lose to West Ham yeah you do not you can
get relegated but you don't lose to West
Ham cuz that that kills me at work for
the week yeah so we knew pretty early
that that was that was what it was all
about and you had to make sure you
always you know won your dares true
that's so fascinating so what was what
was your next move from there so I went
I went from Mil to Sheffield Shield to
Palace and then came out to New Zealand
in 2009 so how did you end up in New
Zealand yeah so that was a that was a
weird one so my contract was running out
of Palace but like I said i' had a
terrible time there I've been injured a
lot but they somehow offered me a new
contract and said we give you another
year um and I just thought I don't think
my body's going to get through it was
just Relentless in England you play
Saturday Tuesday Saturday Tuesday you
know 50 odd Games 55 games really oh two
games a week two for the most part and I
just felt like cuz the way my hammies
were going i' I'd seen a Physio and he'd
said you might need to retire if this
keeps going on and I'd in another
specialist and he said oh I think you
just need to stop sprinting and I'm like
well a professional football I work yeah
you know what I mean and and I was quick
that was my thing yeah that was almost
my superpow so to take that away I
thought I'm I'm done playing
professional football so I was in the
gym one day again rehabing and a mate of
mine called Nick car who is an Aussie
boy said to me would you ever consider
playing in Australia and I said oh
that's miles away and he said no but it
would suit you you know it's warmer
there the game's a little bit slower um
you probably could end up not sprinting
and you be fine in that level they play
once a week on the weekend you haven't
got you haven't got a backup you that's
30 Games a season you could potentially
live on on the goal Coast or the central
coast and he showing me pictures of you
know the Gold Coast I'm thinking oh
maybe maybe that could be me and he said
he knew I was like a pretty laidback
person he's like look you know it would
really suit your sort of character so he
said why don't you just speak to my
agent so I spoke to his agent a guy
called Tony RIS and and he said I might
be able to get you a place at Central
coost Mariners that sounds good to me so
he said just do a bit of research online
so I'll go and speak to my wife and said
look do you fancy just getting out of
here and doing something completely
different she said where I said let's go
to Australia so so we're having a look
and Central Coast Mariners pitch is
right on the beach like literally
surrounded by palm trees golden sand
perfect photo it was a banger honestly
I'm like that could be us um so we said
yeah let's let's let's do it so I spoke
to the agent we agreed a deal everything
was going through you know sold up at
home had a part going away party oh you
sold your we went for it we the way I
figured it I thought we go for a year
and if we don't like it we come back and
we'll start again here if we do like it
we'll you know we'll stay so that was
you know what we're going to do and the
day the deal was going through I got a
phone call um from my agent said the
deal's off what do you mean the deal's
off some I'm flying this afternoon he
said no the deal's off I said why so the
Central Coast Mariners were part owned
by Sheffield United my former Club a
director from the Central Coach Mar has
spoken to a director of football at
Sheffield United and said we're just
about to sign Paul arfield what can you
tell him are might have a gambling
problem um maybe liable to go missing
injury-prone don't sign him yeah come
back to get me yes I'm like Jesus Christ
I'm like this could Scupper all my moves
yeah you know so I went back to the
drawing board um we were staying we were
staying in a I think we had to rent a
place it's a long time ago I think we
had to rent a place I'm renting a place
right by the old training ground at
Crystal Palace yeah I can literally hear
my teammates training every day and I'm
across the road on the park you know
running trying to keep myself fit and
and waiting for a move and I got a call
from Brighton which is where I'm from
and would you come down yeah and they
asked me asked me to trial but it was
the league below so I was a bit put out
that they wanted me to trial when I'd
played you know high level but I thought
a it's home so I spoke to my mom she
still lived in Brighton she was excited
about me being home so went down I'm
tring with the club and it's it's going
okay but I'm thinking I don't really
want to drop too much in wages I'm
dropping a league as well so the only
thing really the only plus really was
the fact that it was home so I spoke to
my wife to maybe maybe I sign for
Brighton then got a phone call from um
the agent again oh we've got a we've got
another offer from the same league from
the Wellington Phoenix I said where's
Wellington he said oh cap up with New
Zealand I said ah that doesn't sound as
inciting as the go coach or Central
Coach he said look it's a good deal um
you'd be going on on better money that
you're going to be on um it's a club
trying to build blah blah blah
Wellington's a cool City blah blah blah
he lied to me told me that the weather
was similar to Australia me being me not
checking so well and being so L back
just went with it so we we agreed to
come and um I fly in middle of July um
get up to ockland and I'm thinking this
is cool Oakland's nice yeah flying to
Wellington is absolutely pissing down
the planes all over the place you as you
come in I'm like oh my God what what
have I done so get into get into the
accommodation they've given me and then
there was a knock on the door and Chris
Greener who is a good friend of mine he
he'd signed a few months before me and
he came in and he said look you'll
absolutely love it here like don't
stress it's a really cool Club Great
owner good boys um you're going to be
all right so went into training I was
useless the first couple of days and
there's a few stories that go around
they were like what have we
signed I was just so jetlagged and and I
was not sure I was where I was supposed
to be if you know what I mean it took me
a little bit of time to get to get used
to the boys and and the level and but
then once I started playing everything
just went according to plan and ground
and I found on the level less lesser
than what I've been playing I felt sort
of fitter and stronger than everybody
and I just thought and really started
enjoy my football yeah um and had a
probably my my best season most
enjoyable season anyway in your career I
think so
yeah it was cool really really good
bunch of boys like we were the massive
underdogs like we were supposed to
finish bottom and get the wooden spoon
yeah and we were one game away from from
winning it we got to the semi and lost
in the semi so did you cash at you bit
no yeah yeah well back then and I
probably shouldn't say this but I was I
was betting on myself to score first in
games and um which is definitely highly
illegal you get suspended now but um
yeah I scored a few first first goals in
every week yeah I was scoring a lot of
goals that year a lot of goals so yeah
it was good yeah I was living in
Wellington at the time and I remember
seeing you at the Courtney Place t
almost so I had an apartment just up
there as well and I used to pop down as
I us remember always seeing you there
and just thinking oh man he
loves yeah so your gambling was still
pretty heavy at this point yeah so when
I when I first came over um we basically
decided that I needed to get out of the
environment as well because like in
England there's such a gambling so
prevalent that you you're in the change
room and and the boys have got their
computers on and the smartphones and
everybody's I've got this tip I've got
that tip so you're just you're just in
it you're doing it you're gambling
you're playing football you're gambling
you're playing football and I just
thought maybe a new environment I don't
know any you know people who
G no tipers all that sort of stuff so I
thought that might be good so when I
arrived in um in Wellington I think I
went about 6 months without gambling oh
and I thought I'd cracked it I thought
I'm that's me I'm off um and then same
thing happened I think I can't remember
who we signed but somebody else came
into the squad and they liked a little
bit of a bet and off to the casino with
them when we were on a way trips you
know down to Dun Eden or Christ Church
we went down there and then it started
and that's probably when you Des send me
in the T that was sort of my the end of
my first year and then it slowly started
coming around again and I was I was back
on it so um gambled for most of the time
at the Phoenix but probably the level
had come down a little bit I think that
was more because I was getting the buzz
from the football as well yeah staying
fit so it wasn't like I was searching
for I was barely injured that first
season I think I played every single
game yeah um so wasn't really didn't
have as much time yeah so did you see it
as obviously get the big buzz from
scoring a goal yeah did you basically
see it as a replacement for that 100%
it's the only thing that gets close in
my opinion you know I think I was I was
forunate I was a sort of player that
especially at the Phoenix I'd get the
ball sort of in the final third and the
crowd would stand up yeah and you you
got 10,000 people chanting name how do
you how do you replicate that yeah um
and the only way I could replicate that
was that sort of feel it wasn't the same
but it was close yeah um and you know
now I coach and I don't get that same
buzz from coaching again that's close
but it's not it's nothing like playing
yeah that's fascina so your danger times
on the punt were when you were injured
and had too much time on your head
pretty much and a lot of money and a lot
of money so near most of the time you
know and I don't think you forecast very
well as well because like I said you
feel invincible so you're sort of
thinking ah when I stopped playing I'll
just stop gambling yeah think think
you're that you're that powerful you're
that strong to be able to do that that
mentally strong and then you I retired
early through through injury yeah and at
that point when I retired I'd actually
been off the punt for a while and that
that sent me again because I was like oh
my God I rupted my kiles I'm probably
never going to play again and my wife my
wife's Nana died around about the same
time so she'd gone back to England left
me at home with the kids two young kids
and I couldn't literally couldn't get
off the sofa it was that first week
where you you know you just feet up yeah
and I'm on the sofa absolutely bored and
I'm just like and I I went on and got a
credit card um delivered like 24-hour
delivery paid paid the extra to get the
delivery and spent 10 grand in about 2
days did your wife know no not at the
time she got so she's going back to you
know bury a n this worst timing for me
and she gets back and after she got in
and I just told her straight away and
she was devastated crying her eyes out
cuz she thought I'd been off it yeah
what's your relationship with your wife
in terms of your gambling like was she
always anti it for you always anti once
she realized it was a problem I think
the early days she didn't realize it was
a problem you know still going out to
nice places buying nice cars nice
holidays everything's cool but then I
think once she realized that it was
taking place when I was injured she
started thinking oh maybe he's got a
problem yeah and then there were times
when you know come the end of the month
I couldn't pay for stuff she's like she
knew at this point what I was on you
know earning £9,000 a week and you can't
pay the mortgage or we can't go up for
dinner yeah so then it was like what's
going on so you know slowly but surely I
told her and she understood and well
there was one time when I was at
Sheffield and I'll tell this story when
I come in speak to the rugby boys but
I'd um I'd signed from Mil to Sheffield
United and um my agent had managed to
get me 15% of the transfer fee so I
think I went for a million pound 150
Grand put in my account £ 150,000 I had
a signning on fee the other end and I
had a loyal bonus the other end so I had
about £250,000 put in my bank so
$500,000 sort of in today's money yeah
and I spent it in six weeks far yeah six
weeks um again through meeting Keith
Gillespie and up in my bets and I was
just you know you know betting online so
it didn't really feel real and it's just
coming at my account anding at my
account and we'd found a house and I
think we ended up we had that's PID like
£15,000 to buy this house and you know
deposit and stamp J it and all that sort
of bits and pieces and she Rings me you
know 6 weeks after we we've got up there
and she's like the house is going
through today so I'm like okay no
problem said you need to go and get a
cashier check for £15,000 or whatever I
said yeah no worries so I ring the bank
to get it all sorted and they're like
you haven't got that in in your account
I'm like oh I must have put it in my
savings can you check their savings no
there's nothing in there I said can tell
me what I've got left in my account I
£6,000 oh so I'm like [__] so you had no
idea how much had idea was there I was
just spending it thinking you know you
win a bit you lose a bit you win a bit
lose a bit but you always feel that
you're in front yeah you do you always
feel about even might even be in front a
little bit and then I'm like [__] so I'm
I'm going through the the statements cuz
I had a bet 365 account and a l books
account I'm looking for them and I'm
like [__] I've lost way more than I
actually realized here yeah so I'm
thinking I've got like a day or two to
get this money together otherwise she's
going to know everything yeah and at
that point probably she didn't know too
much so I remember ringing my mom mom's
a chef like at a local school and she
she she got a loan out um she's given me
a savings I rang a mate to get some
money I went to my own bank to get a
loan I went to my other bank to get a
loan I scrambled all the money together
and we bought the house so I thought
nail this no
idea so then we we've had we've had our
eldest Ry
um and then I get back from training one
day and I don't know Roman was a couple
of months old or whatever and I walk
through the door and ry's in the in the
baby in the car seat um and there's all
these suitcases and I'm thinking oh this
is this is not a good sign so I walk in
the front room and there's [__] Bits
of Paper all over the floor and I'm like
what's going on and she's like they all
our [__] bank statements we've got
how we've got no money left and I'm like
and we didn't even have a joint account
I actually Managed IT yeah and I just I
came clean and said like yeah we've got
nothing out to borrow everything to get
the house and and I swore blind that I'd
never gamble again yeah she left um we
split up for 3 months she moved she
moved home really all right so I drove
down there you know when I when I could
to try and sort of win her back and yeah
I'll get counseling again I'll do
whatever I need to do so we got back
together I quit for few weeks and then
back on it and back in those days there
you could still um smoke in the in the
in The Bookies oh yeah yeah so I used to
go into the bookies and have a whole
change of clothes to change into to get
out of smell clothes go back in you you
been oh we had double training s um and
it's weird like I like to think I'm a
pretty honest person but with the
gambling I would tell any lie to not
have to tell people what I was actually
up to it's crazy yeah like just no
control like did you when you see that
you were giving up did you believe it or
you always knew that You' just be
straight back on I think I believed it
in the moment yeah um and I used to get
a buzz from walking past The Bookies and
not going in yeah so it was almost like
well I've I've got this yeah um and then
it would just take one one bad day or
one bad training session or an argument
with the wife and i' I just i' I'd use
that I'd almost use it as a tool to go
now I deserve to go another B and to
make myself feel better and get that
buzz and then I was back on it again
yeah um and it was it was like that for
the best part of probably 20 21 22 years
F right yeah so your
wife you end up getting back with your
wife obviously how did you manage that
just sweet talking yeah just sweet
talking doing all the right things
saying all the right things and
promising I wouldn't Gamble and you know
she'd heard it all before but I think
you know by this point we we had a had a
baby together and it was like I think
she came back really more because she
wanted that sense of family and I think
I've never really asked her but I think
probably she stuck with me for a lot of
it because I was the father of the child
and and that was what she wanted to hold
on to and she probably thought she could
change me and for the most part I was a
pretty good person I think she was
thinking if I can just change this one
thing I can do all the other [__] that
he does um and and bless her she she
stuck at it for a long time yeah and how
many other times did she find out and
there was we split up on three different
occasions over pretty much over the
gambling yeah um I think we had a 3
month split up another 3 months and then
maybe like a six five or six months five
or six months was just before we came
out to New Zealand oh yeah and then I
sat down with her said you know let's go
and let's just try and start again and
hopefully it'll be different over there
and for the most part it was you know
there was there was some some parts
where it wasn't great but I could I
think I could manage it a little bit
better because I was playing yeah and I
wasn't wasn't injured yeah so that
conversation when she's fled to the UK
to see herun whatever that is a tough
one broken up three it was it was
horrible but I give her credit she I
think she almost gave me that one and I
think she knew how much I was hurting
because my achilles was ring and I was
33 when I red my achilles yeah and I
think she knew that I was done yeah um
and I think she thought [__] hopefully
this is his last Harrah yeah I'll give
him the benefit of the doubt this one so
she was don't she was fuming but I
thought she'd leave yeah you I thought I
was done and and I think she just saw me
I just look suck of [__] on the sofa
you know in a cast and yeah I was a
sorry State you know I mean I think she
felt a little sorry for me so gave me
the benefit of the doubt and we we
worked through it I got at that point I
was going to counseling for the fact
that I was retiring so I was seeking a
little bit of help to work out what's
next so we sorted out some of the
gambling issues there and and they they
kind of helped me through it but the
problem was I was on I think I was on
insurance at that point so I was still
earn the same money but not playing oh
okay so I was still gambling yeah um and
that should have been the time where I
should have been going right there's no
there's nothing after this like you're
probably not playing like put this all
away just in case and and I didn't um
and then you get to 35 and you realize
you are fully retired yeah now what but
you still got that buzz you still want
to gamble yeah and I think that that
period probably those next two years
were probably even harder than the rest
of it because the money wasn't coming in
yeah and I'm still trying to gamble and
at this point you know we are suddenly
struggling to pay mortgages and we are
not able to get credit because I don't
work and I've gone into coaching and I
didn't know what I was doing as a coach
you know you sort of think oh I've
played played in the Premier League
Coach P pit and you guy it's like holy
[__] this is this is so different and I
was still at that point I was still
trying to be although I couldn't play as
a pro I could play at that level you
know and I was trying to play and coach
and it was just a mess to be honest how
did you survive obviously you you're
making huge money throughout your whole
career um when you do come to the Finish
obviously everyone I speak to finds it
one of theough transitions they'll have
but you still trying to gamble while
having no income like how how how did
you survive um I I started up my own
Academy I was doing one-on-one coaching
sessions on the side um I started my
sort of speaking journey I suppose I was
going into rugby clubs at that point I
was going into schools um a good friend
of my wife's actually put me um on I
think he was working for Rico or Fuji
zerox at the time and he would have me G
and speak to the school kids and he' try
and sell a photocopy of at the same time
um and that was kind of where I learned
to speak I suppose and it was great with
the kids because they were just buzzing
to have you there so you could mess up
your whole talk you know doing know
these presentations would get them wrong
forget what I was talking about but they
didn't care yeah so it was a great place
to learn um and I suppose out of that
then I got a couple of rugby gigs um
early on through Ben Sigman who was my
old teammate at the Lions I think was my
first ever one I remember he invited me
to do that and I was absolutely [__]
myself and I walk into a room of guys
who make me look so small and I was
quite a big footballer yeah and I'm just
thinking this what am I doing here and
it wasn't flash you know it wasn't you
know um very smooth but they gave me the
time of day and they seemed interested
and I came out of there and thought [__]
that was what a buzz that was yeah and
then I just sort sat down with Sig and
said I just need to polish this up a
little bit and you know get bit talking
points get a bit of pictures make sure
my story is a little bit smoother yeah
and then just cracked on on doing that
so there was there was money coming in
nowhere near as much but I was kind of
doing whatever it took to just keep
paying the bills yeah my wife was
working full-time and earning good money
so so it it had kind of flipped because
I'd always been the one earning the
money and I didn't like that at all so
it's was like right I need to I need to
make sure that I'm at least earning the
same money because it just didn't feel
right to me and your gambling obviously
dropped significantly in terms I could
couldn't afford it but then I was still
getting enough of a buzz because I
wasn't earning that sort of money still
a percentage of exactly she's still like
well that could make if I win that could
still make a significant difference to
us this month this week and that's what
you tell yourself yeah so it was yeah I
was still on the slippery slope but
didn't really realize it so you were
still speaking to the um Rugby teams
about gam gaming and still gambling yeah
and I think that was the that was the
thing so i' I'd done probably about 18
months of that yeah and what I did is
when I went in I would mostly say to the
guys look I'm not here to sort of tell
you what to do and what not to do this
is more a cautionary tale don't end up
like me so I didn't feel like too much
of a fraud but I also remember coming
away thinking [__] I think I could help
more if at the end of it I could be
saying well you know this is how I
stopped and this is why I stopped and
these are the things that help me and
the the speaking was going really well
and I felt like I was you know just a
much better speaker and I felt more
confident going into these these things
and uh Steve Simmons who was at the
Hurricanes um said to me look I want to
get you in front of all the pdas yeah um
and I thought that sounds a bit daunting
but yeah I'd like to do it so we agreed
to do it so went in spoke to all the
pdas and and it went really well it was
cool and they asked me really good
questions at the end as they would and
we I had two PD come up and speak to me
at the end and and Steve was one of them
and he said um he said you're still
gambling that's the first thing he said
he said you're still gambling I said how
do you know he said I've been around
enough people that that gamble to now he
said you're still having a pant AR I
said yeah yeah he said M you've got to
stop you've got to stop he said I want
to meet your wife and I said why why do
you want to meet my wife he went what an
incredible woman she must be to stick
with you through all of this and now
you're not even playing yeah and I was
like holy [__] I hadn't really properly
thought about it until he said that and
he said do me a favor he said um go home
today and buy some flowers um and have a
think about you know what you done over
the years and I said Steve if I buy some
flowers she's going to be thinking I've
gambled or cheated or both so I said I'm
in trouble I'll never buy flowers he
said we should buy flowers more often
anyway um and weird timing but my radio
in my car had stopped working so I I was
living in the W raer this is in
Wellington so you know two hours yeah so
I'm in the car and I cannot get his
words out of my head and all the way
home I'm like [__] I'm just going to do
it so went and bought flowers went in
wife's there she's you know finished
work gave her the flowers what are these
for what have you done I said and I told
her the story
and she's like so you telling me you're
going to stop gambling I said I'm going
to and she started laughing because I
told her you know 50,000 times I stop I
said babe I can't explain it but Steve
got me at the right time and I was I was
happy to hear it and she like okay we'll
just see how we go and this time is
quite weird but yesterday was the
Melbourne cup and I stopped on the
Melbourne cup six years ago oh six years
and and I watched the Melbourne Cup
yesterday just as a spectator no no bet
on it and it was you know wasn't that
exciting beest right but um yeah it just
just weird and then I got um you know my
eldest is 17 so she knows what I've been
through and she sent me she sent me a
message and it it made me cry yeah um I
like to think I'm tough is not super
tough but that it got me and it was it
was her saying how proud she was of me
um you know being able to speak about it
and and being open with it and actually
still being you know on the straight and
narrow that was pretty cool moment yeah
g me goosebumps got me it's got me
talking about it but she got me I was
telling cuz the boys in my team that I
coach they know that I'm off it yeah um
and I told them about it last night and
like we're going we play Friday and we
actually going to the races on Saturday
oh yeah and it's now I'm at a point
where I can go to the races and know
that I just won't have a bet and I'm
fine and I never thought I'd be able to
get to that again I probably won't enjoy
it too much I'll have a few drinks and
that'll be all right but w't I probably
won't watch too much the racing but yeah
I'm look back you know seven eight years
ago to think I'd be able to do that is
just ridiculous yeah so it's so
interesting around like what Steve um
spoke about and like obviously I see
people who have issues never quite know
what to say or like you want to help
them out but you don't really know how
because a lot of guys don't want to hear
hear it and I think that's the thing I
look back and I had I had one mate who
from honestly the time I started at 15
till the time I finished would try and
stop me gambling every single day yeah
like what a guy and he I'd always say no
I said I don't got problem like leave it
and I look back and think [__] you know
fair play to him there was a lot of my
mates who just completely me and loved
loved that I gambled with me let's go
let's go to the casino till 3 in the
morning don't worry about your football
and you have a lot of Hangers On and
then when you finish those guys you know
Fall by the wayside but yeah I've got
one mate who who stuck with and
obviously my wife who who stuck with and
and and was trying to stop me trying to
stop me and I think it didn't matter
what they said cuz I wasn't ready and
then Steve just got me at the right time
but I think I my message has always been
just keep trying because at some point
they will be ready yeah um and that's
hard to do yeah like you got to be prop
a good good friend and and want to help
so it's difficult did it help coming
from someone else cuz I think about that
your mate who was obviously trying for a
long time and never really gave up same
with your wife kept trying to tell you
but um Steve who was obviously just
probably a random sort of blow you I
think so I think I think though Steve
had a bit of manner about him as well
like he you know whenever he spoke with
with the rugby guys at the Lions or at
the Hurricanes again you see a r full of
big hard men kind of just listening to
what he had to say yeah and I thought in
sort of maybe subconsciously I thought
if a guy like that can command that sort
of respect he's obviously taking a a
thought about you yeah um it might be
worth listening to and that's not to say
anybody else is not worth listening to
but I think it was a mixture of timing
and who said it and how he said it he
kind of made me step back and see the
bigger picture and I think I'd always
been so blinkered and it's almost like
with my money I'm earning it if I want
to spend it that's up to me yeah um and
I think he take he made me take a little
step back and go well okay what's next
yeah cuz at some point she's going to
leave and not come back and then are you
you know are you willing to give up
family and at this point we you know two
kids two girls um and I wasn't and I
think that's what kind of got me across
the line so you obviously had more
control over it than you probably
thought you did yeah maybe I don't know
I but I think I turned it round I almost
went right how do I turn this into a
competition yeah so it's like I know
that I can do this and then I would just
tick off the weeks and then I'd get
excited about it and I'd be to M done
four weeks and eight weeks and then we'd
start celebrating it you know we
celebrate at 6 months and then the year
you know we'd go on holiday um and for
the most part normally she's actually
away on a bloody horse track so
yesterday I was the only on my own
celebrate on my own um but yeah like
most times we we'll go somewhere we do
something you know take the kids out and
you know they understand what it's about
and it's it's pretty cool that we can we
can do that so I it's it's weird though
because I have dreams where I gamble oh
yeah and I and I wake up in a proper
sweat like absolutely gutted with myself
and then I'm like oh
you know you realize you're on your
pillow and you're like cuz I just know
what the Fallout would be you know what
I mean she she's gone so um yeah that's
that's a little weird but yeah it's I'm
six years in and I'm still dreaming
about so it's always there you know what
I mean it's always there and you always
worries you know like being an alcoholic
or addicted or anything you always got
to be on your guard and be careful and
for the most part I just keep myself
right out of it so you know like I said
this weekend will be a bit of a test
I've said to the boys in my team I said
you know I've not been in a position
where I've been at the races and
drinking I've been at the races with the
family and not had a drink and it was
fine so I've said to some of my my boys
in the team look keep an eye on me if if
you don't mind I I think I'll be fine
yeah but you know you have to have a
drink you know it's like your
inhibitions go a little bit and it's all
exciting so I don't want to fall off the
wagon this weekend that's for sure well
hopefully a lot of people listening will
yeah they can keep keep me away shut put
the shutters down on the to please yeah
oh that's crazy so when you see someone
who is obviously in a similar sort of
situation obviously not throwing the
same amount of money down but like what
what would you be saying to them now I
think I get that when I when I go and
speak to the boys in the rugby and you
can sort of tell by the questions you
get sometimes you get questions from
people that are not gambling but they're
worried about their mates yeah and you
can sort of see um I can get a sense of
the room and who is having a pun I think
I might be wrong but but I think and
then you get the feedback I think it's
more it's pretty obvious when you're
you've been in yeah cuz you know the
telltale signs and you know the
questions you would ask and to the PD
after and they're like yeah you know
we've had a couple of people reach out
and say that you know the talk helped
and they've Now sort of admitted that
they might have an issue so I think that
gives me a bit of a buzz as well it's
nice to be able to help and I always
think you know if you go in and speak to
25 people if you can just get that one
guy to maybe come forward or or even
speak to a mate about it then you've
kind of done done your job and that
becomes quite a bit of a bit of a buzz
yeah and what would the like um GA
meetings and stuff what were they like
for you the counseling sessions were
they cuz people always quite intimidated
about you have to find the right person
yeah um I went for a number of different
counselors and and some of them I found
they probably weren't but I found them
like condescending almost talking down
to you as if you know you're this this
scallywag who can't get off the punt and
it's like you know I'm just a normal guy
I just need a bit of help and I found
one lady in England who was class um and
just would just let me speak and just
waffle away and then would just offer
kind of real um things that I found
pertinent at the time that would help m
um she was class and then I found
another one over here um later on when I
retired um a guy and I had a couple of
sessions with him and he really helped
as well so I think with that stuff is
finding someone you've got a connection
with um and that's not always easy and
it depends whether you're getting some
support from somebody is it going to be
paid for that was the other thing I
remember there was times when I needed
needed help and I couldn't afford it
yeah so when I retired and it's like
what do you do you just do it on your
own it's like I'm I'm gambling so I've
got no money but I've definitely got no
money for counseling what do I do here
so it's yeah you in a bit of a you're in
a bit of a spot but I think yeah from my
my point of view I think it's finding
somebody that that will support you and
will listen and and you have a proper
connection with and you can be as open
and honest as possible I think my wife
always found that really difficult but I
wasn't open and honest with her but yeah
I could go and talk to a complete
stranger or a room of complete strangers
when I do the rugby stuff yeah but I
think that ended up helping yeah um I'd
always go in with the rugby stuff and
I'd feel so much better afterwards and
then I'd come home and speak to my wife
about what I'd talked about and there
were stories that you guys would have
known before she knew yeah and she knows
it all now and I'm in the middle of
writing a book I've finished the book
now yeah um so she's read she's read
that first draft oh true when's it
released I keep saying this this
Christmas but it won't be this Christmas
but we we're literally done um we're
looking at releasing it for next
Christmas I'm with Jason Pine the the
broadcas um he approached me again when
I ruptur my killes you knew I'd be on
the sofa so we we started this nearly 10
years ago been that long yeah but so
some stuff happens we're like well that
needs to be in that has to be in and
he's like and then we we we get it done
and he's like well we won the treble
this year with my team so he's like well
we need to include that you might never
do that again so I think the problem is
we need to put a stop on it and go right
okay there might need to be book two but
we've finished book one so we have
finished um I'm hopeful that's out at
Christmas but that will I think that
will stir up a little bit of interest
because like this is the first time I've
spoke about gambling on anybody's
podcast oh really yeah normally I I keep
that to myself cuz I want it for the
book yeah um but I just felt with with
yourself and um the way you approached
it I thought let's let's let's get it
out there might appreciate it and
hopefully it um it brings a lot of
attention to the book Because when that
does come out like there there's enough
um jeez there's enough of a teaser in
here to make you make me want to read
get the book straight away as well CU
I'm sure there's plenty of other stories
in there so you've spoke about a little
bit around life after Sport and how hard
that was very common on the podcast and
how difficult that um transition is what
was the hardest thing for you like what
did you miss the most yeah just the the
buzz of playing like training the the
train room as well yeah there there's
there's just nothing like that um the
things you you can say in there you you
can't say in normal society can you I'll
look at some of the conversation you
think [__] you couldn't do that you know
um especially over in England I don't
know how it compared for you but it was
it was toned down here for sure but in
England like I look back to some of the
things that were said and done and
you're like I'm just glad there were no
camera phones around you know to be to
be recorded but a lot was questionable I
think everything's so PC now and you
have to be really careful what you're
saying I've got no problem with that but
it's so different to what I grew up with
um and they're the things you miss and I
think that's why a lot of people go into
coaching not necessarily as a head coach
but you find people wanting to be you
know kit man or you want to come and
help out with strength and conditioning
it's more just to be around the boys get
a pay packet as well but it beats going
out and getting a a real job so to speak
so and you sort of kept playing too like
I've played right up until this year oh
really I made what's it 10 years uh 10
years since I retired supposedly yeah so
uh this year last year I played a bit
and then this year I've only played like
if we've had injury crisis and we had I
think in the cup one time I played 45
minutes and then I come off the bench
with our second to last League game and
actually Nick to goal so I think I'll
probably be the oldest goal scorer in
the sudden League at 43 um but yeah the
the buzz to play is still there I still
I'll turn out next year for some Masters
team or whatever I can manage because I
think you're a long time retired and
people that I've spoken to that sort of
quit in their mid-30s and then tried to
come back and play Masters 5 years later
going well it's too late done and I
think the more people I speak to they're
like just keep going because then you
don't really lose it it's all these
people that that quit come back and
think they can still Sprint again and
then everything falls apart it's a touch
wood at the moment my body's actually in
pretty good Nick true so when you had
your career ending injury what what was
that and how like how did you get back
out there yes I did my rupture my
achilles um I did 16 months of
rehab and then the doctor basically said
look you're not going to be able to play
at the level again my my killes was so
so tight felt like I couldn't Sprint I
was so scared to to push off it um so I
did some training sessions with the
Phoenix and I I was just miles off it I
decided I'd drop down a level um to sort
of our national league here and I went
to team Wellington um under a bit of
fanfare you know dropping down blah blah
blah and
awful sorry my first game was actually
okay and I thought I'm all right I can I
can do this and then I played I ended up
playing 10 games didn't score a goal
yeah and I was taking the place of
others that had been doing well and it
was just it was embarrassing like I
nearly went to the coach when please
just put me on misery just leave me out
and and I was probably a a reason why we
didn't quite make it to to win the
league that year yeah and we' I think
we'd been right in the mix um so that
was that was embarrassing but I just
thought oh maybe maybe my time is now
maybe it's you know call it a day and
then I got offer the job as a player
coach at w Raa which is sort of again
the league below that Central League um
and slowly but surely the K just got
better and better and better and and I'd
gone from a position where at Team well
where I couldn't push off the bad side
so it made me slower because I was
always thinking I have to push off the
good side so you couldn't react to
things it was almost like I'll ease my
way into it so I'd lost that extra bit
of pace yeah I could still you know do
the bits and pieces but I just wasn't
anywhere near as explosive and then
slowly that started coming back bear in
mind I'm now 35 36 um and I had a good
season there then I signed for Hawks Bay
in the National League did okay there
and then I went to Tasman United in the
National League and I think I was 38 and
I was second top scorer in the league
that was more for me I kept playing cuz
I was almost like I was so embarrassed
by what happened at Team Wellington and
there was a lot of talk how he's
finished and team Wellington didn't want
me back and and I went down Tasman I was
like no I'm going to give it one more
real crack are you getting paid at this
point getting paid but like family's not
moving with you no no I was going on my
own so the how it worked back in those
days you had the sort of regional league
and then you went into franchise
football it's a bit like bit like the
rugby um so then i' I'd go off and join
Hawks Bay for three months and travel up
and back and I went down to Tasman so I
was flying down on like a Wednesday and
staying to the weekend and going home oh
true but Tasman was a great Club it was
a new club and I ended up I think I got
20 goals in 25 games so it was kind of a
f you to everybody to go I'm still here
I can still I can still do it yeah um
and then I carried on playing um sort of
in the winter season for w rapper and
always did okay um we always had a young
team there so I was a sort of Elder
Statesman yeah but it was good fun
trying to bring the bring the kids
through and then when did coaching take
over or I was I was coaching the time
but it the
coaching I again I was just so far out
of my depth I just didn't I didn't see
the game as a coach I saw the game as a
player so I think I was really good at
the Players might tell you different but
I F I felt like I was good at sort of
managing and working with the players
and understanding what they needed and
how to get them up for games but I
didn't really understand the bits and
pieces around the game and the tactics
and I yeah and I think that's taken me a
little bit of time to get to and I think
I'm still not there um I've got a really
good assistant now who's who's
tactically unbelievable you know he's
like a analyst and and a tactical guy
rolled into one so he does a lot of the
coaching and kind of lets me do what I'm
good at I think I'm good at the
individual stuff so you know I I I'm in
the session and I'm I'm sort of as
you're going to receive the ball and
you've done that I'll talk to you about
what else you could have done and just
the little bits and pieces almost the
micro coaching and I think that suits me
more so I think that's what I like and
that's how we work together that very
cool so what's your next sort of plans
for you yeah I don't know I've not
really like with the when I started out
as a footballer you you know want to
play in the Premier League you want to
play in the FA Cup Final you want to
play the country I've never really sat
down and thought any of that with the
coaching um I still think I'm too far
away and still learning the game but I
think the good thing about it is I know
that I don't know much so there's so
much more to learn and I think I've done
okay up to now so I think if I can
really get my head down over these next
couple of years I've it could take me
somewhere you know beyond where I
thought I could get to so that's quite
cool the back of this year like I said
we won the treble um didn't think that
would be ever possible
I'm I'm moving clubs I'm leaving Christ
Church um and I'll be heading back to
Wellington for a new club um so that's
that's pretty exciting that that that's
going to take place back home yeah see
the family again and do something
hopefully build something again um like
we've done down here oh this cool what
club in Wellington I can't tell
you for the book yeah the another
chapter yeah yeah and addendum at the
end no there's um there's only two weeks
left so it'll be announced in a couple
of weeks but um nothing completely done
yet we much agreed you know to go too
early after absolutely yeah I don't want
to put it out there yes exactly exactly
so yeah so that's that's me for the
future more more coaching less playing
yeah um pick up a master side back in
Wellington like I said um more speaking
I love speaking love doing this um you
know whether it's podcast whether it's
going in and doing public speaking I did
a little bit of um corporate speaking
which is pretty cool really enjoyed that
that was just before covid So Co kind of
put pay to that but I'd love to get back
into that that was that was pretty fun
yeah mate you're so good at it how do
people book you like what's the yeah
that's a good question that's maybe the
that's maybe the problem I just sort of
started getting into that and then and
then I suppose hit me up on socials um
I'm I'm available you know whether it's
after dinner speaking whether it's
lunchtime speaking whether it's corate
birthdays I I dress up as a
clown I suppose I think there's there's
a few strings to my bow I can go in and
speak about the gambling but sometimes
you know I got got invited into to do
some corporate stuff and it was actually
talking about resilience and then you
put a sort of you know presentation
together around what that looks like in
the workplace and revert it back to what
I was doing so there's there's plenty of
of ways I suppose I can get out and
about but I think once the book's out I
think that will help as well 100% um
that's that's what I'm hoping oh M man
of many talents well I have gone to the
Instagram for some questions um usually
get a few good ones in um you've
answered that first one someone knew you
were punting first goal scorer um next
question was what was your biggest
collect um I had a i it's ridiculous I
had £50,000 um on a boxing match once oh
wow who was it you remember the fight
well surely it
was a it was a title fight it was
Tyson versus Lewis I think oh yeah but
Tyson was favorite oh yeah yeah and I'd
read I can't remember who somebody had
had even a monster bet like a proper
celebrity yeah um better had said why
would the champion be the underdog and
had pumped like a million bucks it and I
just thought he good enough good enough
for little old
man I want to say he was even money and
the other other uh and and tison was
odds on yeah um I'll have to look at
that one but that was that was the
collect but again I lost it all in the
next next three days or something stupid
yeah I think I've had one time where
we've actually made some money and
bought something and I'll tell that
story we not going with the rugby but
um the the betting companies had worked
out with the addict that they'd have
time off and time on so they used to
send us money so I'd get an email
through and it would say hi Paul we see
you haven't been betting with us for the
last couple of weeks here
£500 so as soon as I got that oh free
money yay so so I'd go on and this one
day I was at Sheffield at the time 2005
maybe
and they send me 500 and I'm sat there
and I was just playing on my computer at
the time on my laptop and logged in saw
it thought no I'm not going to spend it
on horse racing cuz just started like
online casino lb Brooks or William Hill
whatever who had sent it so I'm started
playing
roulette and M my numbers would just I
always do the same numbers they would
absolutely just flying in and I'm like
Jesus Christ this is ridiculous and my
wife so I here my wife sitting on the
sofa opposite and at the time I was
supposed to be off yeah and and I'm like
I said babe you need to come and see
this so I turned the thing around and
like £ 35,000 from 500 gone mad and
she'd never seen anything like it she
and I'm pointing at the thing and she's
like Is that real money I said yeah and
she's like no way I said this I swear
this online casino I explain they sent
me money you shouldn't be gambling but
but that's a lot of money that's a lot
of money I said what do you want to do
and she said let's get something with it
for the first time ever what do you want
she like always wanted a hot tub so I'm
like okay so I said so we going online
now on the phones trying to work out how
much a hot tub cost so I said right we
put that we put that aside and then we
gambl the rest so she sat there with me
yeah gambling on roulette and we lost
the rest of it but we put enough money I
think we put away 14 got her got her in
yeah so we spent £20,000 in like an
afternoon on on gambling but we we put
£14,000 away for this [__] Super
Flash eight person hot tub with all the
bits and pieces right so we go to the
shop we we buy the hot tub and they're
like right we'll get it on the back of a
thing and we'll bring it up to the house
and we we'll put it in and it's all for
the all in the cost excellent yeah so
she Rings me about a week later my wife
and she's like oh there's a problem they
they can't get out the road the road's
too too tight so we're going have to
find another way to get in I said well
tell them to that you know this must
happen all the time yeah so they said
well we can do it but you have to shut
the road so we go to the council we get
the road shut can't do it can't do it so
we' spent all this money on getting the
C still can't do it so I'm like well
I've bought this hot tub now I need the
hot I'm not going to move house to get
the hot tub in so we end up having to
shut the road and hire a helicopter to
helicopter the hot tub in right so by by
the time we've done all of that it cost
more to do all of that than it did for
the hot tub so I actually ended up
paying about D the price was about
28,000 bloody pound for this the hot tub
barely we barely used it barely used it
um yeah I ended up giving it to Ellie my
wife's parents actually and they had it
they had it and used it a lot so it got
some did they have the helicopter it out
they no they we had to helicopter it
back out and then it it moved it went
from Sheffield all the way down to
Somerset which is hundreds of miles on
the back of this flatbed and then they
managed to get it in so yeah they had a
better deal out than we did that's so
funny and that reminded me of a um one
of your investment yars around the was
it you own a petrol station or something
I'm part owner of a petrol station in
Sierra Leone so how did that one happen
that was from my agent um I had an agent
called Andy Gray um he good player used
to play for Crystal Palace in the
Premier League um played for England
once I think and and he was my agent he
was he was a senior player at M when I
first got there yeah and he became my
agent from there so he went straight
into agency and approached me and I was
like yeah you know knew him as a as a
player real good guy so he was my agent
he looked after me sort of first few
contracts and then he went off to Sierra
Leon and got involved in like part owner
of a diamond mine that that went to [__]
and then he came up with this new idea
that he was going to take petrol from
one side of Si Leone to the other side
of s Leone go over the border and sell
the petrol there and make like you know
ridiculous profit so me being me and
thought this sounds amazing it's like a
gamble again you RIS massive risk I'm
like oh and he told me that we were
going to uh my my um Stak was going to
be I think it was £24,000 but I was
going to get 2,000 a month from that
from that and I was thinking no brainer
you know one year you get your money
back yeah how can I lose so so I invest
and he's over there and he's sending me
pictures of this bloody petrol station
and oh yeah we're nearly there is you
know we're finishing this and we're
finishing that and and I'm checking in
with him checking in with him and you
know nothing's happening no money's
coming through and I was just thinking
and then my wife found out what i' done
and she's like where's the contract I'm
like oh no he's my agent right he's
always looked after he's not going to
sting me um but he was over there for 3
years I think in the end and it it never
got never got off the ground like I he I
think he ended up splitting up with his
wife and all sorts you know what I mean
it was one of them where he he'd gone
all in yeah and I think because he went
all in I was I was happy to back him and
I knew he lost everything as well so it
was like well so I've never really even
even chased it so I've got a picture of
my petrol station somewhere it must be
in my aous somewhere but that that's all
I ever bloody toce for for the best part
of $50,000 so even when I tried to do
the right thing it it didn't work so I
was never going to make money you know F
off cam yeah sort gave up like well I
tried oh that's the next one biggest
loss um oh God don't
know there were so many yeah you know
they were more cumulative than anything
yeah um I was never one to go I I'll
stick you know that one time 50,000 but
other than that my biggest bets were
probably five maybe 10,000 other things
I thought real Bankers they weren't and
I'd lose here and there but it was just
cumulative I'd go in The Bookies you
know i' I'd get 4,000 out and I'd go in
the bookage for the day yeah and then
I'd spend it in a couple of hours and
then I'd go back into the bank and get
another 5,000 out yeah so you know there
were days where I do £10,000 £10,000 and
then go the next day and do the same and
then you're borrowing money to get
through to the end of the month so it's
just it just racked up I was I think I
was earning £99,000 a week at Sheffield
United and Palace and I was probably
spending 10 or 11,000 a week you know
and just keep keep borrowing keep
getting credit and you get the odd win
and just get you across the line for a
little bit so it was just what was
coming in was going out so I mean I
tried to work it out when I started
doing the the gambling talks for the
rugby and I I reckon it was about I lost
about2 million 2 million throughout your
career career wow yeah yeah it hurts
yeah no now I'm looking at oh Jesus
Christ I could have just put a little
bit away it's a few hot tubs no it's a
few hot tubs it's a house yeah don't
care okay um next one What stopped you
from becoming one of the all-time
greats my mindset and my self talk I I
do believe I could have played at the
Premier League for a lot longer yeah um
I don't believe I believed in myself
enough and I think I've relied too much
on the words of of coaches and others I
was I was the guy that would finish a
game and search it out somebody
hammering me online I try and find it
you know even if i' had a good game
I'd skipping through the the I feel was
great today I'd be where's where's the
guy that's hammering me yeah and then
I'd dwell on that like [__] like oh yeah
I must and then suddenly I've gone from
having a good game to having a bad game
because of one guy's opinion or you know
one coach or that
was when I say it now it seems
ridiculous but I was that person I was
always trying to search out the one that
would hammer me yeah and it held you
back it held me back massively my self
talk was awful at times um and that's
what I'd really try and get into the
kids and say that you know your selft
talk is your biggest weapon and it can
absolutely kill you if you can't sort of
regulate it and it's it's a skill it's a
good point and with did social media you
mentioned social media they when did
that sort of really take off in your
that wasn't at the start of my career so
I didn't have to worry about that you
know you pick up the paper and you get
your you get your number yeah I will
tell as if i' been good or I can't
remember what they used to say when I
was [__] there was a few headlines but M
you you honestly you get your Sunday
paper and they'd Mark you at 10 oh yeah
and that every week that would actually
be how you felt for the week if you got
nine you'd be Bing into training on the
you know star man it used to be Nine
Star man yeah star man this week must
have cracked it and then you next week
you get five or something and you
honestly believe that this guy that
probably watched four minutes of your
game was so informed about how you'd
been in that game and and you'd live on
that yeah so that was our social media
before social media then it goes Twitter
Facebook and then there's people writing
essays about you yeah and then there's
Twitter people hammering you you know
for how you play how you look what you
wore and if you're the sort of person
that buys into that you in all sorts of
trouble and I was I was that guy
searching it out again and you know just
You' read a Facebook thing and then
sometimes you get involved with it and
you messaging people and then it's just
it's just a it's just a mess and I don't
know how I don't know how people deal
with it today it's it's it's another
level if you were starting your career
now would you would you ban social I
would I would try I would try I think
I'd just get off of everything and just
be like right I'm just going to try and
concentrate because it it just takes up
so much of your time you know even now
it takes up my time and I'm not playing
so yeah yeah so off all socials off all
bookmakers I think so I think so I'd
have been on the straight know wouldn't
I I'd have been pretty boring done I
wish I could have learned to be a good
golfer oh yeah I've got so many mates
who were really good at golf and that's
just what they did and and and they
still live in big houses and drive nice
cars and have got good investment so I
think if if I can tell you one get into
the golf guys get into golf yeah TR that
is it's like time consuming it's like
six days of year un least you'd probably
be punting while playing that would be
problem I think but I think if i' have
got in the golf before the p in I'd have
been all right but the minute I got into
the pun in I think if I'd have gone to
play golf I'd have been gambling on the
golf you look at like Michael Jordan I
reckon he's he's horrific for you know
so but he can afford it so it's a little
different okay next one greatest goal
ever
scored too many oh I'd love to say that
no not enough not enough
um there's there's a couple that stand
out there was one in the playoffs with
the Phoenix um when I'd missed chance
after chance in normal time and went
extra time and it's quite an iconic when
I score against Newcastle and run try
and run the full length of the pitch to
celebrate with the yell fa and just blow
a gasket on halfway and just sort of put
my arms up and then all my my teammates
were like what are you doing why are you
running you know you knackered and then
I was rubbish for the rest of the game
couldn't move I think I end up getting
taken off actually um and then probably
my favorite goal was a goal I scored
against Central Coast Mariners and Tim
Brown who's the founder of all birds
actually was playing m oh yeah yeah he
he plays an unbelievable ball over the
top I go through and I hit it with the
outside of my wrong foot and it just
goes straight in the top corner and you
can see the keeper just go like he can't
believe what I've done yeah and it's one
of them where I'd been trying it in
training for the last couple of weeks
and the boys were getting angry with me
because it I'd just be missing and
kicking it into the keeper and it was
just one of the moments I've probably
not done it before not done it since but
it just worked on the day and I
absolutely love watching that it gets
posted every now and again um but I
don't think people realize how difficult
it was yeah um and I think it was just
the level of difficulty of that and the
fact that I've been working on it that's
probably my favorite gun oh Magic I'll
have to bring it up from the yeah easy
okay two more um how far away the all
whites away from being genuine
contenders at the World
Cup I think this is a good group they've
got now I think it's the best group I've
since I've been in the country um and I
like Darin basley I know there's a few
not sure but I think he's really
improved as a coach and I think he could
be the guy to get the best out of him I
think the the fact that the Phoenix are
now sort of on the up and up Olay
Academy have been doing really good
things over the years I think there's a
really good group of young players that
he can work with um and you've still got
the old heads you know your your your
Chris woods and guys like that to sort
of look after those younger ones I think
this could be it if you can keep
somebody like a s sing fit he's had a
lot of injury issues if you can keep him
fit there's you know there's not a
better sort of attacking midfielder in
this part of the world anyway so it's a
it's a good group hopefully basley can
get the best out of them and this could
be the next one that we're going out you
know we have a little little nudg maybe
getting out of a group it's nice to get
to a World Cup if you could get out into
the Knockouts imagine that imagine that
oh exciting times exciting times for the
all Whits okay last question best piece
of advice you have for a waterair
listener if we're just if we're just
going advice generally I think I think
it's try and find a way to regulate your
self talk I'm I'm such a big believer in
that I'd love to go back to the start of
my career and just work on that cuz I
think I had enough ability to to go to
the top yeah and I did okay don't get me
wrong but I think so many things I
taught myself out of yeah what would
that look like now like I think I think
it's just it's a skill so I think it's
just almost every time um it's almost
having short-term memory on your
mistakes and long-term memory on your
successes yeah um and what does that
look like what does that feel like and I
think you know visualization as well and
just using all the tools that are now
more normal I think in our day it wasn't
you were either seen as as a tough guy
or soft and soft normally me mentally
yeah and I think that's just dumb um and
you know dumb coaches and I try not to
be a dumb coach I'm thinking how else
can we get those little bits and pieces
out of players you know we saying oh
he's soft he's he's not well okay what's
going on in the background you know how
can we how can we turn him into that guy
that you want what does that look like
and that's not not easy at all and I
have conversations with the young boys
all the time about trying to regulate
yourself talk but I think you know
nowadays it's more normal to see sport
psychologist when we were coming through
yeah you speak to your coach and he
hammers you you go into your shell and
then you start telling yourself you're
rubbish and you are rubbish go find the
abuse and and some of them are okay and
I had guys I played with they could take
that and they were resilient and you
know they'd come from backgrounds that
made them resilient so that sort of
hammering for Coach didn't matter their
selft talk was always good and real
confident guys I I wasn't that guy
unfortunately I was a little bit shy a
little bit reserved so I needed to find
a way to to be better and think better
of myself so I think that's the if I
yeah if I could go back that would be
the the the main ingredient I think that
would make such a big difference to my
career I love that what a way to finish
one of the great podcasts like M I've
been wanting to get on for a while like
I KN once every time I've heard you
speak like I said it's been awesome and
um big issue in the game I think um
needs to be addressed more people need
to be able to speak about it more so
that people can hear um they're not the
only ones in those situations so M
really appreciate you coming on being
honest and vulnerable and um yeah what a
y and if people do want to um read your
book when it's out make sure you get
that book him if you want him to speak
yeah I'd love to love to do more
probably more importantly if he's if you
see him at the line at recording on
Saturday just shove me out I've got no
problem with a bit of physical abuse
yeah SL me back around the corner sit me
down but appreciate you coming on man
it's been awesome top man thank you
you're